hey folks uh I'm part of the organizing
committee and when the opportunity to
introduce our last keynote of the
conference came up I jumped on it
because for one personally I owe a lot
to Peter Wong for his support and my new
fund
um but I just wanted to also highlight
for folks here for pi data nerds who
might be just into the tech and all of
his accomplishments in Python and the
Sci-Fi and Scientific Python World know
what a great business leader he is so
he's been CEO for a little over three
years and in that short time has really
taken the company to some new heights
and has continued his great support of
the Python Community including the num
Focus dividend he's
closed some big Partnerships with
snowflake
Microsoft Azure and Oracle including an
investment by snowflake but let me turn
it over to one of the people that I
think knows python better than just
about anybody other than some of the
core developers and the Creator himself
so Peter Wong our final Keynote
thank you thank you very much uh for
that very kind introduction and um uh
you know it's usually better if you set
the bar low so you can uh overachieve
rather than set a very high bar like
that I'm sure there are plenty of people
here in this room who know
um more things about python than I do in
many ways and uh and actually one of my
things that I've done I've enjoyed the
most has been coming up with a lot of
crazy ideas and then making them someone
else's problem uh so a lot of the crepe
projects and open source things that now
have taken root and that we've created
at anaconda or incubated
um have become like so I sort of birthed
the puppies and make them someone have
someone else raise them which is maybe a
skill maybe a curse I don't know but um
but uh I you know I actually the last
time I was here at Pi data Seattle was
in 2015 was anyone here at that event
other than me all right do y'all
remember the PowerPoint karaoke they
made me do at the end
it was it was awesome they sprung it on
me at the last minute which I really
appreciated and uh the Steve dower and
shirok and some others were just
advancing random slides or I think
there's a picture of meerkats there's
some other stuff and I had to come up
with something to say and I thought
about you know actually kind of fun to
redo that this time but with chat GPT
and then I realized no that's going to
be a complete chaos and like that's not
what anyone allows to hear so I decided
not to do that Sperry that instead I'll
talk about something much much more um
encouraging and hopeful and optimistic
which is will open data science lead to
the end of the world at least the end of
the human populated world right
um and sorry just as a spoiler I'm not
going to actually answer this question
but I'll be speaking to it in some ways
throughout the entire talk so let's
start by just taking a look back that
was on the left here we have
um Pi data 2015 if she wrote down there
you know Mount Rockland Jay fonder plus
Brian Granger lots of good people
um it was a really really fantastic
event and as always we're very very
grateful to Microsoft for providing us a
brilliant venue for it and now this year
you know it's it's grown there's of
course now so many more people using
python data science much more diverse
representation of practitioners and
speakers it's so great
um but in looking at this you know the
question is how do we actually whoa
that's that's a lot better is this
better can you guys
is a little bed right here all right
great wow I didn't know this was just
like we turned it to 11 right here okay
um
but if we look at um
how how we sort of got here why why was
there such an adoption
um the my theory behind it
this is okay
how about this right here so my theory
behind why why we got so much adoption
is because really there was an
opportunity at the time to pick up
Grassroots usage in all these places
that it had basically cordoned off and
so how many of you work in a larger
business where you have to kind of go
through a lot of it Hoops to get stuff
done show of hands two hands over there
that person that's extra pain right
there a lot of pain in each hand
um and so if for those of you who don't
know because a lot of people didn't
raise your hands there are actually
maybe I'll turn this guy on
hello oh come on
is this fine oh okay all right great
well
even on lapel was okay oh okay
I just like being louder but okay fine
we'll turn it back down to eight
um
so if you for those of you who did not
raise your hands the the double-handed
pain that that person is expressing uh
comes from the fact that for a long time
now businesses managed overall sort of
Technology as a word
um they've managed Information Systems
by really sorting them into a few silos
and these are the major ones one of them
is infrastructure computers the systems
the networking how do you operationalize
and manage deployments another Silo is
data management you know things like
data governance privacy database
architectures and which databases to use
all these different kinds of things and
then another one is analytics which is
usually smaller actually because a lot
of businesses are not very analytical
they run on spreadsheets and shoot from
the hip so
um so the analytics units usually have
you know but sometimes they drive a lot
of compute okay but they do have to go
and do modeling of you know what came in
and what does this mean and produce
another spreadsheet for somebody else
and that's where some of the older
analysis language just like SAS and
older tools like that got used and what
happened is that we had multiple
technical disruptions coming in all the
same time in the 2000s Big Data of
course uh you know over I guess 15 years
ago started transforming things the
mainstream adoption of cloud computing
and the early early sort of machine
learning applications and all of these
things just blew up the silos and so
what happened is when you have tools
like open source python or open source R
anyone can just pick these up and start
using them and in fact what's really
interesting is if you if you think about
it the overlap between any two of these
failed silos if you look at these as
silos from above the overlap of use
cases that were not being adequately
served by any of these silos they sort
of emerged into new little practice
areas data engineering when that first
started showing up as a term outside of
DBA and data warehouse kind of stuff it
was because people were trying to Cobble
together cloud architectures and nosql
stuff and a bunch of Python scripts and
some other stuff and that became kind of
data engineering and a lot of like
the modern data stack stuff is sort of
outgrowth of that now
and in the intersection of the needs of
advanced analytics and it not providing
the amount of computers that they needed
to do those analytics or the kinds of
computers kinds of gpus
you had rushing into this space a lot of
that early adoption of python and that
then in the conversions of all of these
things was this nebulous group of just
lost orphaned children essentially doing
really important work but they sort of
would all go and meet at conferences
like open data science or they'd go to
strata or they come to Pi data or they
go to our user conference right and so
really the emergence the adoption going
back to that first slide why do we have
so much growth and usage we have so many
more people here this is great the
reason is because there was an under uh
served set of use cases that were
clearly valuable it wasn't just Child's
Play it was clearly generating value and
insight for business and that's where
really open data science kind of came to
the to fruition and one of the key
things here is the word open in open
data science right and those of you who
are familiar uh with the with the open
source movement which is you know
related of course
um we use that word open to mean several
different kinds of things right and
we've you you know they're sort of like
does open mean free right if it's open
source it means you can get it and use
it for free like free as a beer right
which is the what the open source people
have been saying for a long time
um does open mean that I can read the
source code and over here is the source
code breakdown for sci-fi how many of
you have read all of that not Travis but
other than Travis how many of you have
read all that Fortran 77 all the C plus
header files right so open source even
though it's you can read The Source most
people don't right
um you just kind of use it because it's
free
but but if you have improvements to
suggest one nice thing about open is
that it's open for for for for
improvement so if you found a bug
somewhere you can submit a patch to
something to you know add some
functionality but even though you can go
and read the source code and even though
you can get it for free you can read the
source code you can even go and write
patches the source code it doesn't
necessarily mean that the main
maintainer Community are open to your
ideas right so open has many different
kinds of meanings when we say open data
science or open source software for data
science that open has a lot of different
meanings and different people mean
different things by that and that's
where we actually get to some
interesting ecosystem sort of breakdowns
but one thing that I think is really
important about this is to recognize
that when businesses adopt this stuff
right it's not actually just about the
licenses it's not about necessarily the
cost of it what it really is is it is
allowing many different people to come
around and innovate together it allows
communities to form collaboration
communities they may not always agree
they may have different perspectives but
because we've reduced the barrier to
adoption and the barrier to usage to so
low you can bring in all sorts of people
that otherwise would have sort of
engaged kept out of the conversation and
in doing this you have a group of you
have a community people a lot of them
are volunteers you know it's free
software they're not getting paid to go
and work on it most of the time but
because they are able to have direct
contact with the users that cycle of
innovation runs faster and that's what's
allowed again this adoption to happen
and then it's allowed the Innovation to
happen because it's an open Innovation
Community but one of the things that I
think oh geez I keep jumping around one
of the things that I think people Miss
in this conversation around open source
and how we love the community I just
came from from pycon
um in Salt Lake City
um and you know people there at pycon
talk about Community all the time it's
so great and that's all they talk about
sometimes it seems like but
um but when they talk about the
community I think one of the things that
that the maybe people who are somewhat
new to the space well certainly people
who are maybe more data practitioners
and not really in the software space
something that you miss sometimes is
that when you're really in this for a
while you realize that the code is not
the important part even it's not about
can you can you can you read the source
code or can you submit pull requests to
the source code what's really important
is actually the source code is actually
an artifact that's the result of a
collaboration
right so so when you look for instance
you think about a band what's important
about a band is that those particular
band members are jamming together and
they produce some of the music so the
music is important of course that they
didn't ever produce music that you could
listen to you probably wouldn't be so
interested in them but a band is more
than just the music
but we and we talk about the bands we
talk about the people but when it comes
to software we don't talk about the
people very much we talk about the code
hey what version of sci-fi are you on
what version of pandas are you using
this distributive system without a
service system right what what app what
thing what thing what thing we're very
focused on the software and we
completely it's like what song do you
like what song do you like what song do
you like and no one ever talks about the
artists no one ever talks about the
Bands
that's kind of the my who is it myopia
it's the blind spot we have as users of
the stuff sometimes right so I I I find
this really really important to stress
to people that software isn't just the
code and for maintainers and
practitioner for maintainers and
developers it's it's also just not a
matter of you writing some code and
shipping it to a bunch of randos on the
Internet it's really about building a
relationship and building that community
and out of that Community better ideas
you know are formed and people have
conversations and so really we can talk
about software as being the artifact or
we can talk about the community that
produces it but we really should see
this thing relatively holistically as
sort of the fruit and the tree that
bears the fruit and in fact there's also
a soil that the tree is grounded in so
if you think about this as you know from
this perspective then I think we can
sort of appreciate that the reason the
pi data Community has grown so much the
reason why uh people have um you know
while we've been able to produce new
Innovations and new projects and even
though some everything's got warts on it
everything's got some rough Edge edges
but people still use it and it still
does the job pretty darn well and that
I'm going to keep my finger off the
keyboard and so
um but that that's that's actually an
intentional result because this
community actually does see itself as a
community and it actually for the most
part you know people who are probably
pretty famous having written pieces of
software if you actually talk to them
you'll be shocked at how much time they
spend managing the people and
personalities and the governance and the
Dynamics around these different projects
so they can continue to yield good fruit
uh in the years to come but even then
one of the things that people even even
people who are in this space and those
maintainers who are appreciate the
community Dynamics there's something
quite radical a perspective I have I
guess but there's a quite a radical
perspective I have that maybe a lot of
people don't have or don't fully
understand which is that open source
software is not actually property it's a
weird economic artifact it's an un
property
and what that is is there's there's very
there's almost nothing else in the world
like it maybe fire but I can't think of
other physical objects where the more of
it that you give away the more there is
um and so this is really really really
screwed up because all of our intuitions
about economic systems about economic
models are not this there's no apple
such that if you cut it a half there's
there's more of it right there's no
there's no stream or no river in the
world that if you if you Dam off one
tributary you get more water out of it
there's not almost nothing in the world
that by itself creates more of this kind
of thing and so the early days of
software there was no such thing I mean
before people really call it software it
was just you know code that people
traded with each other when they spend a
ton of money buying super expensive
hardware and only with the Advent of the
PC and people everyone being able to buy
computers was there now a market a need
for software to run on those computers
and that's you know when people like
Bill Gates came around to really created
the software industry around essentially
a concept and this all kind of formed up
in the 70s and 80s but they used
copyright they used some I basically
some of these kind of Frameworks of IPL
law to take this thing which was
basically unbounded shareable sort of
Jeffersonian I like your candle with
mine and we have you know my flame does
not reduce or whatever whatever the
exact quote is uh that I butchered but
the point is that we had this thing that
was fundamentally generative open
abundant and then we used copyright law
and IP law to actually create some
economics around it now you can argue
whether that's been good or bad I'd
argue it's pretty good that people can
get incented to to you know put in the
hard economic or hard intellectual
laborers to create good software but at
the same time one can maybe argue that
there's there's a way to over rotate on
that right and and have too much of that
so the open source Community the free
software movement uh you know pick your
turn that you want but that
that movement really is a counterculture
and it is
um to some extent antithetical to the
very premise of turning code an
intellectual artifact into property so
every single one of you is a rebel
whether you know it or not every time
you go onto a GitHub tracker and tell
the developer I tried this thing and
this didn't quite work and I think the
bug might be here what you're doing is
you're adding a little bit of fire to a
gigantic roaring fire a little bit of
flame to a gigantic roaring fire over
here that shows the world a different
way that we could be doing all of this
and this is really important because at
Anaconda as a business we do interact
with a lot of other businesses we sell
software to other businesses and when we
talk to them we'll oftentimes come
across potential customers who will
insist that they don't have open source
software they're not allowed to use on
the source or whatever and they're
running Linux everywhere right you know
they've just got all this stuff
everywhere and it's such a really
interesting thing that people is just
how invisible some of the foundational
open source stuff real really has been
but we've transformed all of this stuff
and and really the community that has
created the tools that you all use that
community over the last 10 15 well 20
years to some extent we have really laid
the foundations for
for all the modern ml stuff not all of
it but a lot of the modern ml stuff and
certainly a lot of the AI stuff and the
reason that python is a language for AI
is because the hard work of all the
people in that Community but but at the
end but the reason I want to say this
thing about this on property this weird
economic thing I'll get to later but I
just want to put this out there to for
all of you to recognize that you are
benefiting from an economic interaction
model that is literally antithetical it
is it could not be more Marxist
basically it's completely antithetical
to the current
um General economic schemes in the world
around the commercialization the
propertisation of of uh of intellectual
property or of ideas
okay so one last thing I would say about
this thing the section we'll move to the
next section is that
um the there's a there's a famous
principle in
um whatever software systems or or you
know software management
um which says that it's called Conway's
law and it says that the architecture of
a software system
um ultimately mirrors the organization
structure of the team or teams that
produce that software so if you give a
group of like unless you have a software
Dev team and they have three sub teams
and you say hey I want to build this
kind of an app what you'll end up with
is the architecture for that app that
has three components to it generally or
three layers or three something and if
it was four groups you'd end up with
four layers and if it was a database
team and some other things you would end
up with a thing where there was a heavy
data component being run by the database
team and some other things
um and and the flip side of this um and
it's it's I know it's a bit cheeky to
quote your own Tweets in your slides but
um but people don't necessarily take
this principle and I've seen personally
I've seen this principle validated over
and over in life but
um I think people don't take this
principle far enough which is again this
idea that code is a cultural artifact if
you have closed Source development if
you have a bunch of people getting paid
nine to five to do a miserable job of
writing to some spec they don't care
about for some app they don't care about
they'll never actually see shipping
because it won't ship until years after
they've already quit that job you'll end
up with code that kind of is miserable
you'll end up with apps are kind of
miserable and it's just all sort of
miserable but if you actually have a
lively Community interaction around this
kind of stuff you end up with code that
well maybe it's a little janky sometimes
but it's got there's a certain amount of
love in it so there's a certain amount
of care and quality in it that's
ineffable and so that's I I just really
want to
emphasize that that we keep talking
about we know we talk about software we
can talk about license around software
but the end of the day the really
important thing is the people who
produce these things the cultural
dynamics of those people and and so what
are those culture Dynamics well in the
open source Community it's about that
Community right it's not a place where
people are coming in saying how much
more money can I make if I ship this
line of code it's it's actually a
participatory culture and economics they
call it a gift economy the more you give
the more clout you get right the more
you take care of others the more stuff
comes back to you it's a really
beautiful generative abundant sort of
thing and the important thing here is
that trust in general is the most
important currency
trust in a person trust in a group of
people trust in a brand some some
companies do actually end up earning
trust in the space it's rare but it does
happen and trust is very easily lost
right as we all know so this is a really
important Dynamic of that community and
the Community Values for python in
particular I think are one of the things
that have made it successful when python
first got started back in I mean the 90s
it was just one of these other fun
little toy scripting languages there are
many Pearl was the dominant thing if you
want to write serious code you'd write c
um and then as the web emerged people
started doing things in Pearl and PHP
and and Python and Ruby could do a
little bit of web apps but at the end of
the day python was just yet another
language but what was interesting about
the design of that language and that
Community was that they were quite
welcoming they were quite open to ideas
from randos randos like the numerical
Computing Community who showed up and
said you know what we can overload this
and do that and we can make this thing
almost like a crappy version of Matlab
hey that's a great idea and they
accepted it you know and then that's
like well the crappy version of Matlab
got a little better a little better over
time eventually it got like a lot better
and so the ability for a and this is
really important right because if you uh
for those of you who are live during the
90s and remember that time that was a
very opinionated time on the internet I
don't know what it is like now but it
was very opinion back then and a lot of
people man when they had a cool computer
like language project whatever that was
their thing they were all they just
smeared their ego right over that thing
and you couldn't get in there but the
python Community was more fun I mean it
was you know for those who don't know
python is not after named after a snake
it's named after Monty Python and so on
the mailing list if you go back and look
at The Archives there are a ton of Monty
Python jokes dumb ones good ones I mean
there's a lot of them right so it was
that kind of a fun Community an open
community and frankly a language that
came from a guy who was trying to build
a a thing called computer programming
for everyone right a language or a thing
that allowed everyone in the world to
write code that's very different
conceptually and from a heart it comes
from different heart space than you know
a bunch of Unix bearded Unix hackers
want to make the like the most hardcore
thing possible one of the guys I knew in
um back at Cornell uh who was actually
he helped start the Cornell Linux users
group with me back then uh really really
amazing hacker but his claim to fame was
that he took a three-line pearls there
was a time I think uh implementation of
I think it was RSA and it was in three
lines of pearl he managed to turn into
two lines of pearl I'm like that's not
Pearl that's a cat on your keyboard man
that's not a but anyway we're I mean it
worked it was RSA I guess but the point
is it was there's a whole lot of that
kind of thing going on in the 90s
um and uh and so into that you have
something very different right a space a
language created by somebody who said
let's just use white space let's make it
readable let's just let you know make it
always make it readable right there
should be one obvious way to do it
um and so they welcomed the people that
came in and brought weird ideas like
Travis and others who brought in so many
math ideas and then when when um when
that really sort of took on life of its
own we tried to continue and extend that
right and so one of the things I
remember
um uh well I mean actually we're running
a long time so I should stop with the
reminisces maybe over a beer later but
um by the end of the day I think where
I've come to really reckon one thing
I've come to recognize that the python
community's one of the core values
that's really important is that it is
not about technology just for
Technology's sake right when we when we
actually convene when we're talking at
the you know as a non-focused level or
when I'm talking to psf people at the
python Foundation we're always talking
about education we're talking about how
do we bring in more people into the
community how do we make sure things are
accessible for uh Young Learners and
we're not Young Learners for for who are
newer to the ecosystem at pycon you know
I was sitting next to Eric holster who's
the read the docs write the docs guy and
we were talking about how do we you know
that he he felt that there was a a lack
of Interest now in writing documentation
that's really important because if we
don't have good docs then the stuff
becomes really really unapproachable to
to to to new users and so there's just a
general in the in the in the groundwater
in the ecosystem there's a general
sentiment of really caring about the
people using the technology not just the
tech and I think that is unfortunately
when I've seen from what I've seen I've
been around a lot of different Tech
groups and communities that is
unfortunately really rare it's a very
precious thing here in the python
Community
um and and one one of the important
things now that we've gotten to a point
of adoption where python is so
everywhere it is so ubiquitous and it is
the language of AI one of the
fundamental things that we have to
remember is that a computer language is
not just for people to talk to computers
is for people to be able to communicate
with each other that's why the
readability accounts thing matters so
much and frankly that's one of the
reasons why scipy and and Pi data took
off the way they did is because you
could have somebody
who could write some python code and if
the code was you know not too
inscrutable someone else who maybe knew
it just a little bit could read it and
generally guess what was going on or
they could tweet a couple of things and
it would still basically work and so for
those of you who in town to post covet
era understand what an R value is this
kind of technology has an R value that's
greater than one because it's not just
one lonely hacker turning RSA from three
lines to two it's some really really uh
Haggard astrophysicist or geneticist or
someone who cobbles together some
half-baked notebook and gives it to
their colleague who just learned python
last week and their colleague is
actually able to be productive and
they're able to remix it and they're
able to use it and so you have an R
value that is much much greater than one
actually and so this idea that language
is a human instinct and it's a natural
path to Insight for us that really led
me to this really um I think a very
fundamental fundamental Insight which is
that if computer languages are done well
and they're made usable by every gay
people not just computer nerds and
hackers then it becomes thoughtware not
just software right software makes you
have to click on buttons select drop
downs figure out how to scroll through
something or what set of options will
cause it to do something else
that's that's that's like picking from
that's picking from recipe picking from
menu That's software and generally
software's crap but but if you can
actually build something that feels like
it extends people's ability to think
then you're producing thoughtware that's
a very different kind of thing
okay so that then led to so this kind of
progression in the python Community
um watching all the stuff get adopted
and grow I realize that we're starting
to hit growing limits even
um and I just asked this very
provocative question I guess a very
simple question but how many software
developers are there right if Python's
number one language and python starts
taking over and wins wins whatever that
means
um the language Wars and so many people
are using it we're number one yay but at
the end of the day there's only about 25
million even on a conservative basis if
you really want to go like swing big you
say there's 50 million people in the
world that can code so if we get every
single one of those people they're still
eight and a half billion other people
plus or minus 50 million that can't code
right and so we can talk about literacy
we can talk about access democratized
data science blah blah blah you talk
about this all day long there's eight
billion people who don't get any of it
and that's not a great setup for where
we're going as a civilization and that
is what led last year to creating to to
me coming up with the idea for pi script
and us really pushing it hard now as a
company is just realize that it wasn't
just about the code it was about the
complexity of all of the other crap
that's not the code
right and so you think about how much
every time you spend coding versus how
much of your time you spend fighting
infrastructure debugging yamls going and
figuring out some Cloud containers up or
not going and figuring out what is the
access pattern for this database what's
the schema for that thing or emailing
somebody else for some script for the
other so much of what makes Computing
completely miserable has very little to
do with the language nowadays and
everything to do with the unbounded
amount of complexity that's out there
around the code so what we want to do is
take all of that away and make it so
that at least we go back to a place
where people who have never coded before
can just do something very simple and
get to an environment where they can
write a little code build something that
works and share it with someone else and
so we created Pi script which for those
who don't know is a webassembly based
python runtime it's a framework that
uses an underlying thing called piadite
or micropython and it basically runs
python inside the browser inside the tab
itself just like it was a little bit of
JavaScript and so you can write python
code in line with your HTM ML and it
just runs and it's fantastic and fun if
you haven't checked it out yet go to
pisgrip.com and play with it
and our goal here was to make it so that
it is accessible it is a child's first
instruction of programming that can go
from logo like things to drawing little
things and making animated 2D
Platformers to doing you know webcam
based machine learning machine learning
uh image recognition stuff just all of
it you don't have to install anything
you'll you'll almost never hear the
Anaconda CEO telling you you don't have
to install Anaconda but in this case you
don't have to install Anaconda you just
go to pisgrip.com and you've got it
right and so the idea here is you just
need a text editor you just need a
browser and you're good to go and the
important thing about that is access
because there are so many people in so
many countries so many places that can
get a fiber connection and the latest
and greatest MacBook right this stuff
runs webassembly runs on four billion
devices it runs on Chrome books it runs
on phones and tablets it runs a mobile
mobile browsers across all the major
mobile platforms and so this is
tremendously democratizing for people
and so we want to make the again like it
says we want to make the web a friendly
and hackable place again we want to ease
all those deployment panes for people
and this year pycon we set up a booth
or we're showing how you can yeah again
you just go to Pi script.com or you set
up a local Pi script thing you write
some code and it runs and you literally
ship the HTML to your neighbor and now
they've got the app
so your so your deployment method is
drop into the Dropbox or into the shared
Drive
or zip up the HTML and email it to them
that's your deployment method and that's
that's just such a game changer in terms
of ease of use compared to teaching
someone here's how you set up a cloud
key here's your stuff this other thing
create this machine image and blah blah
so so we we were very very excited about
this
and then I don't know if you guys
noticed but around November this thing
called Chachi BT showed up and I said
well I guess all you have to do now to
write code is just to ask something to
write the code
which is kind of cool right
um but the interesting thing about chat
gbt is that it wasn't just it wasn't
just the underlying gbt model because
that's been around for a little while it
was the interface was so simple and
again coming back to that whole thing
about accessibility if you make it
because language is a where is it here
language is a human instinct so if you
give a natural language interface then
that's the most natural interface you
can provide to a human almost
um
so when you have something like chat gbt
showing up and now everyone in the world
is looking at this thing like wow not
only can I ask it to you know whatever
write Shakespearean poetry or make jokes
or whatever
I can use this thing to actually build
software systems I can make this that an
asset I don't know if those people
who've played around this a little bit
or follow this stuff on on uh on social
media but there is just stuff every
single day
that people are doing that is just
mind-blowing and most of it works that's
the amazing thing it mostly works it
doesn't work all 100 of the time but it
mostly Works
um
and so I think when we think about
access we talk about where is all the
stuff headed well you know this is quite
some success right because the the
adoption of python as a language for
data science information learning
allowed a tremendous amount of evolution
a tremendous amount of innovation and
research to happen which then led to the
creation of things like Transformers and
whatnot and so now we're at a point
where we've hit the next Frontier in
terms of accessibility we've now
unlocked a portal to lots and lots of
people being able to start asking
questions and building Data Systems and
building all these things
and so
um just checking the time here
um
okay that's all I'll say about that so
this next section I guess um uh you know
one of the things that Jose is with with
the gbt stuff we've also got now it's uh
it's so good at making up stuff it's so
good at just coming up with text which
we thought was a human level activity
now we have a lot of people nowadays
talking about
um it leading to the end of the world
and um killing us all and you know we've
had much Dumber things that could have
killed us all over the years and so this
is a very smart thing and maybe kill us
all much more effectively
um and so this next phase of the of the
talk is sort of like um those of you
remember listening to the radio Delilah
so this is now hot takes from playing on
the state of AI right now
um
and so we'll just go through one at a
time let's just stay one at a time
um so number one so the current state of
llm Technology because they're
hallucinators they will require a lot
more work before they can be seriously
deployed at scale in business for a
variety of reasons there are some things
that they can do which are already
amazing for certain kinds of b2c
applications for certain kinds of data
transformation applications it's amazing
what they can do but but before they can
really go into production in business
there's a lot more work that each
business has to do to think about and
one of those reasons is because they are
basically generators right the
problem is that ninety percent of White
Collar work is so there is a
commoditization effect I think it's
euphemism that economists use there's a
commoditization effect that will happen
here
um and then the really the the really
interesting thing is for those of you in
the room who write code is that code
generation Works remarkably well with
these things not it's not perfect but
it's really freaking good and so
um uh you know some naturally software
developers like well crap it doesn't
mean that I'm going to lose my job
because people just write all this code
and I think actually the opportunity is
that there's a lot more software in the
world that could be written that does
not get written today because lots of
people who are suffering in all these
different lines of business all these
little business groups they can't afford
to hire a software developer to solve
their problems so what's going to end up
happening is that all of these people
who otherwise were locked away from
being able to have software automate
their jobs they are going to be able to
self-service in this regard now they
might take a beat and think wait if I
automate away my job
what does that mean right so they might
think about that for a second but but
we'll let them figure that out on their
own every business every business person
has their own sort of figuring out to do
on that one but the ultimate aim the
ultimate thing here is I think that
we're not going to end up with like the
same amount of software and fewer
software developers writing it we're
gonna end up with way more software
written by way more people who are not
software developers and most of it's
gonna be even worse and crappier right
so that's a business opportunity for
many of you here in the room to think
about
the second another really key thing here
is that if we do want to commercialize
large language models we have to solve
the attribution problem there's just no
way around this incredibly big hard rock
this is just something we're going to
have to solve and
um that's not going to rest entirely on
the question of copyright versus fair
use I know right now there's lawsuits
flying there's people luring up lawyers
are going to make a ton of money I
didn't put that in here I should add
that as a bullet point lawyers will make
a ton of money but that doesn't mean
we're going to resolve this in the
battlefield of copyright versus fair use
because there's many other rights data
rights and things like that that fall
that start getting sucked into this
Vortex and all of these
all of the parties fighting because it's
big Tech and AI companies and all the
VCS back in the AI companies on the
other hand you have everyone who's ever
produced any content whatsoever so
you've got Taylor Swift and you've got
JK Rowling and you've got Coldplay and
you've got the Beatles You've got
everybody over here so like this is a
Clash of Titans for real and everyone's
gonna lawyer up and it's going to go
really hard but they're not going to be
able to resolve it on the basis of fair
use versus copyright alone that's my
that's my assertion my hot take
but instead we need a new kind of
holistic licensing model
um that that considers the data in the
authorship of the data that actually
affects the code as well because it's
not just the training data it's not just
the weights it is the particular code
the particular model that then consumes
that checkpoint of the weights and then
produces an inference right
but also the human training efforts the
most important not important but one of
the most distinctive things about Chachi
BT is the amount of human reinforcement
learning data that was included into it
and many people are trying to do this
thing as well recreate new data sets at
some point the humans doing all that are
going to wise up and say whoa whoa hold
on a second I want a piece of I want
some upside in that if I'm going to do
this right so we're going to have an
iteration on this thing but ultimately I
think at the end of the day for this
stuff to actually clear all the
different lawsuits and operate in a
legally clear Zone that makes business
comfortable we're going to have to
fundamentally solve the attribution of
the attribution problem in a way that
yields economic upside to everyone right
and and the reason I bring this up here
is because if anything about open source
that's one of the things that that we
failed to do very well in the open
source Community we talk about
maintainer burnout people can take the
code and use it for free which is great
you also keep doing that but when we go
when we talk to businesses that rely on
this code no one's got budget for any of
it right they just sort of I mean it's
it's it's a big deal for trillion dollar
company to even donate 100 thousand
dollars to some open source project when
in fact that open source project
literally Powers their Core Business and
so we see this happening over and over
again and I'm hoping that as we move
into an era of AI that we will come up
with more Equitable attribution models
and more Equitable economic models for
this
and lastly of course the big question
um I believe AGI is definitely possible
and not only that I believe AGI is
probably inevitable based on what we've
seen
um but but by that I don't necessarily
mean quite what like it's it's not not
like everyone's going to have like a
brain in their pocket I mean you'll
probably have a little brain in your
pocket but
um the idea that there will be something
transhuman intelligent something that is
able to synthesize way more data at way
more scale
and yield predictions that are way more
accurate than any human agent is able to
do I believe that's absolutely happening
or can happen and if you look at the way
the world works today we essentially
have an emergent like horribly baby
slime old version of this happening
anyway in the electronic Capital markets
and in all the online predictive systems
that run so many different aspects of
human Logistics and clearing and
settlement and all these different kinds
of things so for me this is almost this
is almost a subtle question I think
we're going to produce trans human
intelligence and the key question is
what are the values we want to put into
that thing
what are the values
and I think it's unfortunate that we
have to call this out so explicitly but
it's worth calling out based on
everything we've seen from the last 20
30 40 Years of Open Source software that
when we take something that produces
generative economics
where it's a gift economy where people
come in and bring their ideas that work
late nights to sacrifice their chance of
getting uh getting tenure and they throw
it all into this thing and it produces
this beautiful it's almost like a clean
burning or clean whatever uh reacting
nuclear reactor that produces terawatts
of power for an entire for the entire
civilization
we can do all that and then get none of
the economic benefits and the thing has
to get patched up by volunteers working
late at night
and then over here the rest economic
system just keeps running and running
running as if we're still in an
industrial fossil fuel era right
so if we go and we produce transhuman
intelligence
and we have that we upgrade that nuclear
reactor to become this incredible
predictive engine for Humanity and we
plug it right back into the same
economic model what will happen with
that right so the thing that's important
to recognize I know some people here are
maintainers and people who work in the
core of this ecosystem what we've seen
in the last probably five ten years is
that at the end of the day those of us
who work in the open source code
Community we will not get asked our
opinions as to how this thing goes
right they won't ask us for governance
they won't go and hold up and say whoa
hold on we have not actually talked to
this particular maintainer yet in this
GitHub repo and that's really important
piece of software for us they don't care
there is an emergent way the world works
there is a system of the world that
consumes these artifacts with no with no
consideration to the values of the
people of the communities that produce
them they take those artifacts and throw
them into the machine and the Machine
goes faster and better better it goes
faster it goes harder
um so even today if you think about
what's happened in the open source world
when open source goes into a big
business
they still have all the same people all
the same head count doing all sorts of
maybe different things now but they
produce and they continue to run
towering stacks of complexity and they
create these they have to have these
things in order to create sort of a
technological caste system to defend
their budgets to defend their jobs and
that's essentially the way the world
works that's why when I say 90 of White
Collar work is that's that's
that a lot of maintaining that
technological caste system to maintain
the structure of budget
um and so we end up if we continue if we
just take all of this incredible
Innovation that could be coming from
trans human intelligence and we pile it
into that same system well that caste
system just gets fatter maybe a few more
people get brought into the bottom but
it just kind of gets fatter right and we
end up right running into some very
hardcore Marxist critiques of the
entirety of modernity which I don't
necessarily agree with but I'll put up
here just for people to think about
um so again I just want to reiterate
this question that all of you working in
this room inevitably are going to be in
one way or another on the front lines or
at least maybe not front lines the
second lines in this transformation of
the world that's about to happen
and so the important question to really
hold and think about is what are those
values that we want to put in that
system what are my values that I want to
hold as I engage and become one of the
people in the front lines building this
stuff and using the stuff and Advising
people how they should procure the stuff
this is something that we never talked
about as a community back in 2015 this
has been like hey who's that crazy marks
and stuff there what the hell is that
you know his company his family fled
communism and he's up here talking about
all this like you use the word
capitalist up here but the reason I'm
calling this out now is having watched
how the current systems of of of
industry and and whatnot have engaged
and adopted open source over the last 10
years it's absolutely clear to me that
unless we as a community as both a maker
community and a practitioner Community
unless we actually are explicitly
driving this conversation about values
unless we're explicitly driving this
conversation about Equitable economics
around this stuff it will just go the
way it's always gone and that's not
really sustainable I think
so that's it thank you very much
[Applause]